rainieri avete presente quando ogni
tanto a parete la classifica delle app
del telefono e guardate qual è la prima
e vi chiedete ma questo mi fa essere
prima tra tutte le scaricate possibili
oggi voglio rispondere a questa domanda
ho scaricato la prima app più scaricata
del play store helix jump consentire a
leeds jump di accedere alle foto che
cosa te ne fai delle mie foto nudo io
non lo so però se tirarci dell'accesso
vuoi sapere anche quando cago va bene
vuoi sapere chi chiama ok ma io volevo
solo giocare una roba mi chiede anche il
nome di mia mamma però vabbè ok sono
merita si primo posto in classifica a
consiste tutto nel girare devi girare la
roba e far cadere l'acqua o maps ed esce
a livello 1 per passare a livelli così
parte che non mi sembra niente aiuole
quindi l'ho solo girare starò roma che
cagata incredibile ammessa di calcata in
crediti 72 per cento conti ok questo
dovrebbe essere il gioco più scaricato
il play sarà attualmente non vedo a non
devo toccare le cose rosse ma era cagata
assurda quindi non è cagato assurda una
sega quindi il gioco sta semplicemente
nel nostro carrello però se sono perde
va bene io che pensavo fosse una roba
più difficile ok livello 2 passato
veniva il prossimo
tutto questo gioco prima in classifica
posso morire dentro
basta mi sono rotto i trequarti cambiamo
gioco sempre dalla classica alle
classifiche le playlist e ne un altro
che questo che il secondo forse
scaricato che ci my feet non mi
interessa quello che vi vorrei proporre
non può intuire dal nome di gamma aiuto
devono sfilare tutti i coltelli senza
fargli toccare l'uno con l'altro ma la
cagata riceve suda a perché le volte a
novara non è una cagata sembrava facile
bene boss fight questo di infilare i
coltelli più carino l'altro mamma mia
non aveva senso di esistere mostre feed
e poi in matematica faccio schifo per
ognuno alessio dopo filastò coltello la
parola coltello non è family friendly
però come possiamo chiamarlo per evitare
di chiamarlo coltello per tutto il video
così almeno mille monetizzano lo
chiamiamo osvaldo chiamiamolo osvaldo
quando dico osvaldo voi sapete che ira
tavoli al coltello
vai perfetto tutti osvaldi a una
velocità allucinante vai così vai così
ti fai così game e le ok io sono un
fenomeno in questo non sapevo che non
dovevo parlare boss naif unlock ed è qui
che possono equipaggiare diversi con
diversi osvaldi ok ma che carino questo
più carino vai vai così dobbiamo vincere
la vita devi iniziare tutto da zero se
perdi non ho capito perché c'è un
pomodoro
porca vacca no sono un idiota quanto
difficile re start quindi riparte ogni
volta da zero hanno visto quanto è il
mio record ora comunque prova a battere
il mio record che non ho capito quant'è
9 va bene facciamo adesso il record
tanto nomadi quella madonna sono
arrivato allo stage in nove almeno vai
problema far meglio di 9 non mi ricordo
che se ci sono arrivato ma il mio record
va battuto quindi due ho cambiato
coltello 3 come fatto la mia coltello il
controllo del pomodoro 4 ore 9
noi donne limone la da limonaia invece
di giocasta roba vostro figlio qui
quando siamo a 6
io vorrei capire cosa me lo fa fare
nella vita di giocare sta roba che mi
girano le balle cosa me lo fa fare non
lo capisco ho sbloccato il coltello che
le moli col della limone porca vacca ma
ti pare non riesca a fare meglio di nove
impossibile come ho fatto a far 9 altro
che osvaldo per il family friendly qua è
veramente io faccio del male a qualcuno
mojon non riesco arrivare al 98
magari non ce la faccio più ve lo giuro
non lo sto facendo passare una razione
incondizionata quando colpisco un
coltello mi girano le palle
dopo automaticamente quando tac inizia
centrifuga nei miei gesticoli orribile 7
8 rega ci siamo basta ferrarotto basta
new best ha quindi non era arrivata
novero arrivato a ora sette quelli 8 il
mio massimo che fossero arrivato 8 non
arrivare a 10 è impossibile come fai
arrivare a 10
c'è gente che arriva dieci a sta roba
impossibile te lo giuro sembra un fruit
ninja però di quelli che devi lanciare
il telefono è una roba in guardavi non
puoi arrivare a 10 centesimi
il pazzo maniaco ma non c'è niente qua
non c'erano ostacoli come posillipo
speight no erano coltelli quelli a lui
con 10 110 o quante rob è riuscito a
fare 9 decenti
sono contento cosa mi sblocco questa
roba non lo so altra roba sì che bello
sono mamma mia queste per chi non sa
vite sociali
vediamo sempre in store ci regala
qualche altra perla visto che ne abbiamo
viste poche ragazzi e direi lo balls
disegnare le linee bump le palle
mi sembra carino quindi gli sta la
vediamo com'è che roba esce fuori basi
clever nel cos'è sta roba
ma fammi vedere il drago online about
the boys che bella linea dritta ma devo
riuscire a unire le palle va bene devo
quindi devo fare in modo che loro
abbiano due palle riunite ok a proprio
così questo è più rilassante di
spettacoli prima che avrei l'ha
annunciato il telefono quindi molto
meglio è
next ma basta che lo faccio ma scusa ma
dove la difficoltà
arriverà un punto difficile che bello
come padre l'affluenza no ecco scherzavo
che questa è la frequenza a proprio devo
devo creare un sostegno perché sennò non
regge finissimo quero bacheche inventato
sta roba ma che cosa se cosa abbiamo
avuto l'anteprima impossibile
vai 0 ormai che credo delle strutture
miliardo devo fare l'ingegnere lega
perché ho fatto loro numero sbagliato
a per spingerlo questo rispetto alla
fisica sto gioco non è mai scontato dai
vado va ma dai ma che su un idiota ma
riesco a farne anche una roba così
semplice a fermo ok
tali quando fa il corso ok bene va giù
segui seguì my two dal tuo amore brava
la zia mica sempre noi maschi dobbiamo
fare le robe giuste anche voi potete
fare il primo passo donne fate il primo
passo se incastrato non so se non so se
ormai irrecuperabile nave proviamoci
niente perché mi sono incastrato io sono
un idiota ma porca vacca come facesse a
colori no almeno si parlano al telefono
va bene la prima della vacanza occhio
perfetto lega così vi voglio bene
sfavillanti viva l'amore di parma dove
vai tu fermo lì non cadere in tentazione
vai così no
quanto quanto sta piangendo la pipa è
veramente il concetto di gioco e poi si
profondo
vorrei quasi farci una poesia su sta
roba problema è che sono sadico con lo
schifo di non ha prezzo
cos'è sta roba poi come ci arrivo scusa
come faccio l'impossibile ponte che
passa lì in mezzo e cosa no è bravo
esatto 3 euro per i non date voi due
fermi guardali come vela risolvo
guardarli come vela risolvo minchiam
leonardo da vinci chi
ma cosa fa non ho capito neanche io cosa
ho fatto proprio bene da mio dio
[Musica]
ok ci sto riuscendo per miracolo divino
ma va bene così cosa cosa sta succedendo
vabbè raga basta quindi ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto io sono contento
della proprio questi giochi per android
e sono molto superiori
l'ultimo era carino gli altri lasciamo
perdere ragazzi spero che vide vi sia
piaciuto e ho provato questi tre giochi
perché erano un po che volevo farmi do
sulle classifiche di giochi android
questi erano tra i primi quindi 2018
stai facendo giusto però che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi come al solito se video
piaciuto un commento mi piace anche vari
social comitato prescrizione sono stati
siete vi scegliamo da ragazzi
[Musica]